and i get the distinct impression brent
may have been stuck in some traffic in
this antenna
his travels 6 25 here uh well in what's
cool at school a variety of virtual
clubs are keeping kids connected at
o'callaghan middle school
yeah here's bryan loftis with today's
let's go at school
16 virtual clubs during this most
unusual of school years
what's paramount to the success of
students in my opinion that we have to
offer a variety of opportunities
o'callaghan middle school clubs
included yoga chess coding orchestra
drama
dance art music gaming and anime
among others when we found out that we
were going to be online
we had to come up with different ways to
teach them builders club builds items
for the community including meals on
wheels
equality club addresses social justice
and equity
in robotics students coded using virtual
simulations of robots the kids love
robotics and so do i
i love the robotics i love the aha
moments that our kids experience
this is very typical sort of challenge
for our robotics team
members to take on so they're working um
like taking them under their wing
and i really love that that that's
happening an engineering club called
techfit did
so well their work was nationally
recognized in a
purdue university competition they you
know created
it they designed it they programmed it
they engineered it
and then they had to put it in a
national championship um competition
they actually won the championship one
thing not virtual
the winning trophy i probably should
have polished this thing but
uh oh look at that that's a good trumpet
as las vegas starts to
sense a semblance of normalcy teachers
are proud of what they accomplished
it is amazing and it's amazing because
these teachers no one asked them to do
this we give them
a task and then they have to make their
robot
follow the task so i'm highly impressed
with the dedication
of this staff and that's what's cool at
school
thanks brian if you know something
that's cool at school let us know
head to 8newsnow.com click on cool at
school it's under the community tab
or send us an email cool at school eight
news now dot com
love that